>> Sean: VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS
AT THE CENTER MOCKERY YET AGAIN
AFTER THIS BIZARRE MOMENT DURING
A WHITE HOUSE MEETING EARLIER
TODAY WITH THIS DISABILITY
ACTIVISTS WHERE THEY WENT
THROUGH THEIR PRONOUNS AND
DESCRIBED WHAT THEY WERE
WEARING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
FOR, AND TO HAVE THIS VERY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION ABOUT SOME
OF THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES OF
OUR TIME.
I'M KAMALA HARRIS, I AM A WOMAN
SITTING AT THE TABLE WEARING A
BLUE SUIT.
>> Sean: OKAY, AND OF COURSE
THE DAY WOULD NOT BE COMPLETE
WITHOUT YET ANOTHER RAMBLING
WORD SALAD FROM YOUR EVER SO
ARTICULATE VICE PRESIDENT.
AT LEAST SHE IS LET NOT AMBLING.
>> THE COURT TO TAKE AWAY A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS THAT HAD
BEEN RECOGNIZED FROM THE PEOPLE
OF AMERICA WILL IMPACT A LOT OF
PEOPLE INDIFFERENTLY IN SOME
SITUATIONS AND THEN WE NEED TO
BE RESPONSIVE TO THESE ISSUES
AND ALSO LOOK UP TO ALL PEOPLE
WHO WILL BE IMPACTED IN THE WAY
THAT THEY WILL BE IMPACTED.
>> Sean: BUT BIZARRE VERBAL
BLUNDERS ARE THE LEAST OF THE
TROUBLES AS A REPORT LAYS OUT
THE ONE WHICH IS THAT DEMOCRATS
ARE NOT EVEN IMPRESSED WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT ACCORDING TO A
NEW POLL OF A POSSIBLE 2024
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY, HARRIS POLLS
IN SIXTH PLACE BEHIND JOE BIDEN,
POTHOLED MAYOR PETE,
GAVIN NEWSOM AND OTHERS.
AS I LAID OUT ON THE PROGRAM
LAST NIGHT, YOU WATCH, MARK MY
WORDS, HERE'S A PREDICTION EDGE
IT IN STONE, IT'S GOING TO BE
GAVIN NEWSOM WILL BE ANOINTED
THE NEW ANOINTED ONE.
AND THE NEXT DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
MEDIA MOB DARLING.
HERE WITH REACTION,
ATTORNEY GENERAL PAM BONDI WITH
LARA TRUMP.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE TO
BEGIN, SO LAURA, THE FIRST TIME
THIS WAS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION, I AM A WOMAN, I AM
WEARING A BLUE SUIT.
OKAY.
IS FRIENDS OF MINE HAD A CHILD
GO TO BROWN UNIVERSITY FIVE
YEARS AGO AND IT IS ORIENTATION
DAY AND THEN THEY WALKED AROUND
THE COURTYARD AND WOULD ASK HOW
DO YOU LIKE TO BE ADDRESSED?
AND AS LIKE WHAT?
NEVER QUITE HEARD ABOUT THAT
BEFORE.
I DON'T CARE IF PEOPLE FEEL THEY
NEED THAT THEY WANT TO BE
DESCRIBED A CERTAIN WAY.
I WILL RESPECT THEIR WISHES, BUT
TO DOING IT THIS WAY WITH ALL
THE PROBLEMS THIS COUNTRY HAS
SEEMS A LITTLE FRIVOLOUS TO ME.
>> YES, JUST WHEN YOU THINK WE
HAVE HIT ROCK BOTTOM,
KAMALA HARRIS COMES OUT AND
SHOWS YOU THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY
GO LOWER.
THERE IS A LOWER RUNG TO ALL OF
THIS.
AND I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
ASKED THEMSELVES ARE WE
REGRESSING AS A SOCIETY IN
AMERICA?
HERE'S A BIG ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION.
IT FEELS LIKE YES, IF YOU WATCH
THE VIDEO OF KAMALA HARRIS, AND
I THINK IT IS JUST TOTALLY
INSANE AND A LOT OF PEOPLE LOOK
AT THIS AND TOTALLY ROLL THEIR
EYES, BECAUSE MATERIAL POINTS,
SEAN, THIS IS WHAT THE PEOPLE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE ARE FOCUSING ON.
PANDERING AND PRONOUNS.
I MEAN, MY GOODNESS, HE JUST HAD
SENATOR CRUZ ON TALKING ABOUT
THEIR HORRIFIC CRISIS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THERE IS THE BORDERS ARE RIGHT
THERE.
WE HAVE PEOPLE DYING EVERY DAY
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
PEOPLE BEING SOLD LIKE CATTLE
INTO HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A
HORRIFIC SITUATION.
HOW ABOUT THE FENTANYL EPIDEMIC
THAT IS KILLING THE YOUTH IN
AMERICA.
KAMALA HARRIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
HEADING UP THE CHARGE FOR ALL OF
THAT.
OBVIOUSLY WENT DOWN TO THE
BORDER ONE TIME.
FORGET ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE 40 YEAR HIGH INFLATION.
FORGET ABOUT THE HIGH GAS
PRICES.
FORGET ABOUT THE EMBARRASSMENT
ON THE WORLD STAGE AND THE
FAILURE THEY ARE.
THIS IS WHERE OUR GOVERNMENT IS
PUTTING THE EFFORT AND IT IS
REALLY SAD.
AND I WILL TELL YOU ONE THING,
IF I AM XI JINPING OF CHINA AND
LOOKING TO OVERTAKE AMERICA AS
THE SUPERPOWER OF THE WORLD THAT
I SEE A VIDEO LIKE THIS AS
ABSURD AS THIS IS FROM THE
VICE PRESIDENT IN THE
UNITED STATES, MAN, I AM PRETTY
SURE THAT I AM ON THE FAST TRACK
TO OVERTAKING AMERICA AND SADLY
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
>> Sean: I GUESS THIS WILL PAN
OUT IN THE ELECTION, WE HAVE A
MIDTERM COMING UP IN NOVEMBER.
THE FIRST INDICATION WHETHER
PEOPLE ARE HAPPY WITH THEIR
POLICIES AND I DON'T SEE HOW
THEY POSSIBLY COULD.
I CAN'T THINK OF A SINGLE
SUBJECT WHERE THEY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
BUT NOW THERE IS ANOTHER LEVEL
OF THIS AND THAT IS THAT THEY
WANT TO TEACH KIDS ALL OF THIS.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES DOCTORS,
THEY MAKE A GAS WHETHER ABB IS A
BOY OR A GIRL.
THAT IS THE TYPE OF THING THAT
WE HAVE BEEN READING THAT
SCHOOLS WANT TO TEACH KIDS AND
EVEN FIRST GRADE, FOR CRYING OUT
LOUD.
BUT THEY CAN'T DO READING,
WRITING, MATH, AND SCIENCE AND
THEY DON'T OWN COMPUTERS VERY
WELL.
AND WE SPEND MORE PER CAPITA
THAN ANY INDUSTRIALIZED COMPANY,
HOW DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> IT DOESN'T.
AND LOOK AT WHAT THEY ARE
PUTTING IN OUR TEXTBOOKS.
IN FLORIDA WE FOUND THAT THEY
WERE PUTTING IN OUR TEXTBOOKS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MATH, CRITICAL
RACE THEORY, GENDER ORIENTATION
QUESTIONS.
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
AND MATH BOOKS IN MY OWN STATE.
SO'S BOOKS WERE REMOVED FROM THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
AND WHAT WAS SAID ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING ON, AND BY THE WAY, NOT
GOING ON IN JUST ONE OR TWO
UNIVERSITIES, IT IS IN ALMOST
EVERY MAJOR LIBERAL UNIVERSITY
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND I THINK KAMALA HARRIS IS
JUST PANDERING TO THE LEFT AS
FAR LEFT AS SHE CAN GO.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THE
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT LAURA JUST
TALKED ABOUT.
YOU KNOW, AS WITH DONALD TRUMP
ALL AFTERNOON WHEN HE GAVE HIS
POLICY SPEECH AT AMERICA FIRST
POLICY INSTITUTE.
YOU KNOW WHAT SHE SHOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT, WHAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT HERE.
I AM IN D.C., IN HER OWN
BACKYARD, DRIVING HERE TONIGHT
IN THE STUDIO, THERE ARE KIDS
SITTING EVERYWHERE.
D.C. IS A DIFFERENT PLACE THAN
IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO.
SHE SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT
HOMELESS PEOPLE, REGARDLESS OF
WHAT THEIR PRONOUN IS.
IT IS REALLY UNBELIEVABLE THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING IN OUR WORLD
RIGHT NOW.
OUR REPUBLICAN PARTY, OUR SLATE
OF CANDIDATES FOR 2022, THEY ARE
SOME OF THE MOST DIVERSE WE'VE
EVER HAD IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
UNITING OUR COUNTRY AND BECAUSE
THEY ARE QUALIFIED AND BRINGING
PEOPLE TOGETHER, NOT HAVING TO
IDENTIFY WHAT COLOR BLAZER YOU
ARE WEARING.
THAT IS ABSURD TO ME.
>> Sean: WE HAVE THE WORST
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM AS I
MENTIONED, LAURA AND WE PAY MORE
THAN ANY OTHER INDUSTRIALIZED
COUNTRY.
CRIME OUT OF CONTROL IN EVERY
BIG BLUE STATES AND IN EVERY
TOWN IN EVERY CITY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
DEFUND, NO BAIL IS NOT WORKING,
WIDE OPEN BORDERS AS YOU MENTION
TED CRUZ, GAS PRICES AT RECORD
HIGH, 41 YEAR INFLATION HIGH AND
WE WILL FIND OUT THURSDAY IF IT
IS OFFICIAL IF WE ARE IN A
RECESSION ALTHOUGH THEY WANT TO
CHANGE THE DEFINITION OF A
RECESSION.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THEY WOULD
WORK ON LITERALLY SALVAGING THE
MESS THAT THEY HAVE MADE RATHER
THAN FOCUSING ON PRONOUNS.
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD
HEED THAT ADVICE, SEAN, BUT
PERHAPS THEY HAVE JUST GIVEN UP
AT THIS POINT.
BECAUSE AS YOU JUST LAID OUT,
WHAT HAVE THE DEMOCRATS
CONTRIBUTED IN ANY WAY TO
AMERICAN SENT THAT HAVE BEEN
POSITIVE?
THEY HAVE COMPLETELY DESTROYED
THIS COUNTRY ON EVERY FRONT AND
BY EVERY METRIC POSSIBLE.
SO MAYBE THIS IS ALL A
DISTRACTION TECHNIQUE.
HOLD THESE COZY LITTLE FUNCTIONS
AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND TALK
ABOUT PRONOUNS IN AN EFFORT TO
DISTRACT AMERICANS FROM THE
REALITY OF THEIR EVERYDAY
SITUATION WHICH IS DIRE FOR MOST
PEOPLE AT THIS POINT.
BUT I DO WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE
OF ONE THING.
AS BAD AS THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN AND AS CONFIDENT AS
REPUBLICANS ARE HEADING INTO
THESE MIDTERMS, WE CAN NEVER
TAKE ANYTHING FOR GRANTED.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
GET OUT AND VOTE AND MAKE SURE
THAT YOU ARE VOTING FOR THE
RIGHT PEOPLE.
NO WHO YOU ARE VOTING FOR ALL
THE WAY DOWN THE TICKET.
WE CAN LEAVE NOTHING TO CHANCE.
>> Sean: THE LAST 30 SECONDS,
PAM.
>> LAURA IS EXACTLY RIGHT, AND
THIS DOWN RACE THAT WE TALK
ABOUT ALL THE TIME.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY, THE
MAYORS, ALL OF THESE RACES ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE GOING TO
CHANGE OUR COUNTRY AS WELL AS
OUR CONGRESSIONAL AND SENATE
SLATE.
AND THAT IS WHAT IS SO IMPORTANT
FOR A COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT FOCUSING
ON IT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO BECOME AS THE
LEFT AND PROGRESSIVE AS THEY
POSSIBLY CAN BE.
AND WE ARE GOING TO UNITE TO
THIS COUNTRY.
AND I THINK THAT EVERYONE SHOULD
LISTEN TO DONALD TRUMP'S SPEECH
TODAY F